back and what bad you like what is that
let me see that you yeah let me see so
this is a picture I wanted to show you
at the Comedy Store when I was little I
found this one because of documentaries
so this is the one you told me look so I
shaved my eyebrows when I was a kid I
saw my dad shave and I shaved him off so
my mom's grew up this bow cut yeah and
gave me what she calls a girl haircut so
they cannot see my my eyebrows right
there though you're so wide wider and
why yeah we little fat yeah yeah how
would I hold on kid yes oh I love this
kid so mom that picture gets way better
check this out yeah yeah oh man oh man
me and the homie what is that right
there it's a teddy bear oh my god talk
about unfuckable look at that I can't if
I base is based on this photos like no
no no future but you have one this is so
cute dude send it to me I will I'm gonna
send it to me one of the things that
always inspired me about you Bobby that
you didn't give a [ __ ] when you are on
stage like you said what was on your
mind
and I've always there we go aimed to do
oh yeah yeah I'm not supposed to cuss no
yeah I swear I'll kill [ __ ] yeah oh yeah
oh yeah I just seen you at the store you
all was very welcoming do you remember
that I'll never forget the kind gesture
what I got banned from the store for
drawing a dick on the car do you
remember this car it was a manager yeah
the manager at the time he did that
because it was a dirty car so I went and
drew a dick thank you so so I draw the
dick and the guy comes back and he says
hey like I went to go get it buffed out
that thing's not coming out so when you
saw it in the Sun did this yeah like you
could see it kind of holographic graphic
dick
and I was like okay I mean I'm a door
guy there I don't have a lot of money
but I said hey I'll give you 100 bucks
remember I remember it was an it was an
older car like I like a t-bird like a
t-bird yeah that's what it was I
remember now yeah yeah and I said I'll
give you the hundred bucks that you paid
and you know wait you know the next
check and I'll start giving you money
towards another one I mean I [ __ ] up
I'll man up to my Chevy guess who it is
let me guess who it is she's not there
no I know he's not I know who he is he
was kind of a younger yeah guy right he
would go by judge yeah I know him I
liked him he was a nice guy like him
okay go ahead so so I draw the dick he
gets mad
goes over everyone's head emails like
Peter or something like that and [ __ ]
hits a fan like now they're like what's
up with this and at the time I was if
anyone doesn't know just stop Peter shor
is paulie's brother who is basically he
owns the Communist door mm-hmm and this
piece of [ __ ] manager went to the top
wait for a dick drawing on a car in a
comedy parking lot - yeah but you know I
didn't on my [ __ ] car and that's what
used to happen like people started
saying is likewise his getting banned
over a drawing a dick yeah you know they
used to wipe [ __ ] on the car so I was
with Paula at the time I was working
when he was doing that a Polytech
special and so at that time I think yeah
I was already passed and I was on the
road with him so there so a manager was
there that was kind of doing a
consulting work and I got banned like I
like like I got banned for that month
and they're like you know Paulie
shouldn't take you on the road I'm like
so I don't work here so there's no money
coming in the road is the only money I'm
gonna get through Paulie I'm [ __ ] and
then they're like you know maybe your
name won't go up on the wall I'm [ __ ]
up oh so now I'm crying I'm little I cry
very easy so it doesn't say much but and
they get an estimate they say this
thing's gonna be $3,000 right so you
hear about it you're like do
right now I'll give you the money done
deal and I remember telling you it's
like hey man they're trying to teach me
a lesson don't pay that 3000 like yeah
you're trying to teach me a lesson and I
understand what this is I appreciate the
gesture but no thank you you know and
long story short nothing came of it but
Polly still took me on the road and I'll
never forget this so he takes him on the
road he gave me either this long talk
he's like look you got to stop [ __ ]
around because when you do stupid [ __ ]
like this the industry stops [ __ ]
with you because hey this guy's a
problem this guy does pranks this guy
people don't like that and he gave me
this long sincere talk I soaked it in so
we get to Boise we're right yeah and I
love going to radio like that I love
going to morning radio he will let me
tag along
so he's like hey tomorrow 5:00 a.m.
let's meet in the lobby let's go so I
wake up really early I'm winning the
lobby just chillin and the and the
windows of the hotel are like sweaty you
know that morning it was a it was a
teddy bear and a dog oh all right so I'm
doing this and I'm just waiting for
Paulie to get there not here behind me
here oh it's Paulie but jus breathing
and I make eye contact with him he's
like dude what I say he's like I'm gonna
go to radio alone you stay here he told
me about this it's window doodling whoo
we've got a [ __ ] crime window
doodling breath but but here's where it
gets crazy
what the listen are they turn a teacher
door window doodle yes come on I'm
siding with Paul on this one yeah you
ever [ __ ] a window doodle again Wow all
right see what [ __ ] comes around do
the right there bro
that what happens so as if I don't learn
my lesson right so if I don't learn my
lesson we ended up in Cincinnati right
and we go to radio right we come back
paulie's really like he has to take a
number to like he really really has it
going yeah yeah one of these like in the
car like I'm not gonna make oh yeah I
wish I was there I'm busting his balls
were all laughing you know yeah and so
we get in I was saying like on floor I
was thinking like on the third floor
right
and now Paulie was saying like on the
twenty 27th floor whatever so we're
walking we're running in we get in the
elevator he's like all right man I'll
catch up with you later for lunch so
when I get off I grab all the buttons
and I go I push all the buttons I'm like
and I wave at him and the doors closing
slowly as he's holding his side you
[ __ ] up bro I thought we were done so
man has to take a [ __ ] let me get this
right let me get let me get this right
he's on the verge his turtle turtle head
is sticking out of his butthole right
yeah and you get off on the third floor
and you press all the elevator buttons
so it takes him longer to get to his
room take a shirt how is that let me ask
you that is that is that Mexican
thinking what is the what is the endgame
man stupid thinking yeah what that's why
I don't walk around like that anymore I
learned my lesson that definitely is
more of a crime than a doodle yeah
that's a little bit more serious yeah I
[ __ ] very funny though yeah I [ __ ]
yeah yeah what did Paulie say to you
after well I go to my room and I'm like
an anxiety mode just letting out my
shirt you just do things without
thinking that through and that you feel
guilt afterwards that's who you are I
[ __ ] that I was just joking it was
like in the moment joke we were joking
if Paulie was was really struggling I
would have gotten off on a third floor
and [ __ ] in your bathroom that's what
that's what I would have owned yeah I
never
you know what you know you get running
[ __ ] in your bed
right what now opening for him was it a
pleasant experience
yeah any bad experiences or no good me
right now what are you doing
what there's no bad experiences not one
I mean he would get upset sometimes
because I didn't know what I was doing
there are no like um like merge running
the merch line remember I had to do that
one time yeah the merch line is
difficult it's very specific he has a
lot of fans so it's like you know making
sure you're taking pictures and selling
the shirts but there's just me and him
you know yeah I gotta set everything up
and I'm a slow learner so it took me so
long to figure out how to really saw his
merchant
[Music]